[Música]
por muito tempo eu tive uma compreensão
equivocada sobre conhecer sobre saber
fazer algo especialmente algo no
trabalho o meu equívoco foi achado o
desenvolvimento de um bom profissional
tinha uma estratégia aprender a fazer as
atividades tão bem quanto elas poderiam
ser realizadas
então se é algo precisava ser feito
bastava planejar organizar o método e
atrás das melhores evidências
científicas organizar essas informações
e fazer uma estratégia lógica e
suficiente mas o que é suficiente para
formar um bom profissional saber fazer
as atividades não é saber fazer o
trabalho o meu trabalho nosso trabalho o
trabalho de qualquer pessoa em qualquer
profissão em qualquer cargo se relaciona
as conexões que nós fazemos com
experiências com necessidades com hübner
habilidades com gente e gente não é uma
estratégia lógica e simples
então eu precisei me render a
compreensão de que fazer o meu trabalho
não é executar um plano através de um
método para se chegar no resultado e
fazer o meu trabalho é realizar entregas
entregas de valor durante todo o
processo
em todas as conexões e é assim que eu
quero contar um pouquinho da minha
história de como eu fui aprender a fazer
as minhas entregas
eu sou kate dias uma interioranas
sou enfermeira além de atuar na terapia
intensiva neonatal eu sou e consultora
de gestão de serviços de saúde
professora estudante uma psicóloga
informação
há mais de 15 anos eu ajuda as pessoas a
construírem relações que vão melhorar os
seus processos de trabalho
eu sou filha de uma família numerosa e
amorosa
a décima primeira filha de pais não
alfabetizados na minha casa a minha
família nunca deixou faltar ensinamentos
sobre valores humanos
sobre ser forte sobre com paixão sobre a
agir sobre ser gente
mas havia uma preocupação preponderante
ardente especialmente da minha mãe de
que acessar o ensino formal me
desenvolver tecnicamente me desenvolver
profissionalmente era o ponto crucial da
minha vida eu entendi seu internalize ei
eu fiz dessa instrução algo tão forte na
minha identidade que me perceber aluna
estudante sempre esteve em evidência pra
mim e para as pessoas que me conheciam
bom eu reconheço que essa é uma história
confortavelmente comum
acredito que a maioria das pessoas que
estão aqui também aprendeu sobre o valor
imprescindível insubstituível quase
suficiente das nossas habilidades
técnicas
o caminho era evidente então eu estudei
muito e me desenvolver profissionalmente
para fazer o que eu faço a minha
primeira experiência como profissional
foi assumir a liderança de uma equipe de
enfermagem em uma unidade hospitalar
fazia parte do meu dia-a-dia de trabalho
treinar as pessoas para fazer o trabalho
delas acompanhar o desempenho dessas
pessoas fazer procedimentos e muitas
experiências marcar o meu
desenvolvimento mais uma experiência em
especial marcou a maneira como eu me
relaciono com meu desenvolvimento
profissional em um dia comum de trabalho
a minha líder solicitou que eu
realizasse
a medida administrativa a uma pessoa da
nossa equipe havia faltado um dia de
trabalho
em segundo as prerrogativas da
instituição seria realizado uma
advertência formal para alertá-la das
consequências de uma situação legítima
de fácil compreensão
mas era minha primeira experiência e eu
entendi que eu precisava preparar dentro
da minha construção eu me preparei
eu estudei eu planejei aquele encontro
dentro das técnicas de feedback
eu me preparei tecnicamente eu ensaiei
eu me preparei para ouvi-la e muito
segura da atividade que eu ia realizar
chamei essa pessoa e começamos aquela
atividade de trabalho mas eu terminar a
minha fala a expressão dela já começou a
me entregar
eu falei de forma objetiva e prática
fato e conseqüências quando eu pedi que
ela se expressasse a reação dela me
surprendeu ela com poucas frases
expressou-se incompreendida começou a
dizer algo que parecia que ela não sabia
o que estava sentindo ou não sabe o que
dizer
com poucas frases ela desistiu de falar
ela fechou os olhos suspirou de maneira
muito profunda e disse quase de maneira
quase inaudível
que vergonha eu não queria passar por
isso a reação dela me surpreendeu porque
eu esperava argumentos explicações
pactos até a contestações mas como se
prepara para receber a dor do outro
eu vi no rosto dela onde lacerante
constrangimento de estar ali e eu
entendi naquele momento que o meu
preparo técnico para lidar com situações
difíceis estava longe de ser suficiente
eu precisava remodela as minhas
experiências com conhecer a minha
vulnerabilidade eu me sentir frágil
naquele momento
eu não sabia lidar em não ter as
respostas de tanto conhecer essa
armadilha de ter o controle da situação
e das atividades
eu nem percebi vulnerado entende que eu
precisava remodelar o meu jeito de
conhecer naquele momento naquele dia
depois de tanto me preparar anos de
preparo para atuar naquela situação o
recurso que eu usei foi o mais elaborado
e mais inusitado inusitado para mim eu
sou eu chorei na frente daquela
profissional que precisava de mim
naquele momento para conduzir um
processo de aprendizado de troca
esta situação deixou de significar mais
uma atividade de trabalho passou a
significar o encontro o encontro
principalmente comigo mesmo
eu precisava reconfigurar o meu jeito de
aprender a ser gente no trabalho
usar a minha humanidade para acolher a
humanidade das pessoas com as quais eu
precisava me conectar para fazer o meu
trabalho e como nós estamos aqui
dispostos a falar de futuro
dispostos a falar de como o futuro será
incrível é imprescindível e é inevitável
nós reconhecemos que as nossas
habilidades comportamentais as nossas
habilidades humanas relacionadas à nossa
subjetividade a nossa personalidade e
experiências nos colocam de prontidão
para usar o nosso conhecimento
o foco precisava ser não evoluir na
aprendizagem precisava romper com aquilo
que eu estava disposta a aprender e
reaprender a aprender
o profissional do futuro ele é sabe
resolver problemas ter empatia
criatividade ser colaborativo ter
pensamento crítico e boa capacidade de
agir
o profissional do futuro sabe ser gente
no mundo altamente tecnológico o
processo
o fórum mundial de economia traz uma
discussão muito relevante
nesse sentido de que o profissional do
futuro está na capacidade de desenvolver
as suas habilidades humanas e
comportamentais
a maneira como nós produzimos o
conhecimento bens e serviços está em
intensa e acelerada transformação no
nosso mundo pós digital que é o futuro
que já começou
quem nunca ouviu um relato uma piada um
filme
o manifesto nos incentivando até medo da
tecnologia como se essa tecnologia fosse
roubar os nossos trabalhos
esses manifestos são manifestos de medo
de quem ainda não compreendeu que todas
as atividades lógicas previsíveis
repetitivas serão substituídas ou já
foram substituídas são manifestos de
medo de que ainda não entendeu que o
trabalho é fazer entrega conexão é usar
a sua imperfeição a sua vulnerabilidade
para se conectar com a história do outro
com as experiências do outro então nesse
mundo do futuro
eu reconheço que para me transformar
nesse processo de desenvolvimento
profissional eu usei três capacidades
três estratégias rompê com aprender
aprender a aprender desenvolver a minha
sorte que o de aprender em todas as
minhas experiências em qualquer cenário
e não mais aprendem somente no ensino
formal em cursos mas usar cada conexão
cada palavra de cada pessoa de cada
situação para fazer essas conexões a
primeira estratégia que eu recorrer foi
desenvolver o autoconhecimento
não existe conexão com o outro se a
gente não tem conexão com a gente mesmo
eu precisei aprender como eu funciona
para alicerçar a minha inteligência
emocional na compreensão de como eu
penso como eu sinto e isso afeta
diretamente as minhas relações as mesmas
conexões
meu desempenho a segunda estratégia foi
transformar a maneira como eu lidava com
cursos e treinamentos especialmente
cursos e treinamentos que promoveria no
trabalho para desenvolver a minha equipe
à medida que eu participava desses
ambientes de aprendizagem
eu percebi uma dicotomia que me
incomodou muito
uma dicotomia de vamos aprender algo
sobre trabalho e vamos aprender algo
sobre nós como se nós precisássemos de
espaços de situações de maneiras
diferentes para desenvolver hábitos as
nossas habilidades técnicas e as nossas
habilidades comportamentais
não faz sentido não faz sentido treinar
as pessoas nos treinar nos capacitar nas
melhores evidências científicas nas
melhores práticas sem questionarmos
quais as competências quais as minhas
competências dos meus comportamentos
como eu me percebo
nessa situação as nossas habilidades
técnicas nosso conhecimento é vazio se
não vir acompanhado das nossas
capacidades das nossas habilidades
humanas comportamentais as nossas
atitudes de gente
então eu sentia muita falta de espaços
de aprendizagem que conseguissem fazer
que é o mesmo tempo pensar aprendesse
mas também pensar sobre mim e comecei a
oferecer aquilo que sentia falta e eu
uso uma concepção de liderança do
brasileirão que ela diz que liderar é
assumir a responsabilidade de descobrir
o potencial das pessoas e das situações
nesse sentido todas as situações de
aprendizagem que eu me proponho a mediar
a participar
eu saí da minha posição de ensinar algo
para alguém e assumir a posição de
conectar com o potencial daquela pessoa
tem de aprender aquela atividade
e mais principalmente de aprender a
fazer o seu trabalho
usar as suas habilidades
a terceira estratégia para remodelar a
minha maneira de desenvolver foi re
significar a situação que eu vivi na
minha primeira experiência profissional
com conversas difíceis de lidar com
situações difíceis de lidar com o
sentimento com as vulnerabilidades das
pmes das pessoas
eu aprendi primeiro que essas situações
são sempre dolorosas transformar fazer o
outro enxergar algo ou ajudar o outro a
enxergar algo doloroso é sempre doloroso
não há como se preparar para eliminar
esse desconforto é preciso aceitar e
normalizar eles mas o que me fez capaz
de lidar com situações difíceis foi sair
da minha posição de ensinar de mostrar
como fazer de mostrar o quanto você
poderia ter feito diferente e aprendi a
assumir a posição de aprender com uma
pessoa pensa como ela sente e como ela
usa as suas imperfeições e
vulnerabilidades para ser um ser humano
melhor
eu raramente perca a oportunidade de
perguntar às pessoas sobre o trabalho
delas
a maior parte das respostas que eu ouço
são profissões cargos
pelo script que a gente tem na cabeça eu
até consigo visualizar as atividades que
a pessoa faz mas o nosso trabalho não é
sobre as atividades que nós fazemos para
essa pergunta eu respondo que o meu
trabalho é entregar perspectivas
reflexões provocações
o meu trabalho o propósito do meu
trabalho é fazer as pessoas se
compreenderem dentro de uma grande rede
de relacionamento e de aprendizado mútuo
esse agora você me respondesse qual é o
seu trabalho
o que você diria obrigado